공을 한 축을 기준으로 회전시킨 다음 다른 축으로 회전시키면 반대 순서로 두 회전을 했을 때와 결과가 달라요
오늘 Qiskit 교실에서는 이 공이 양자 컴퓨터와 어떤 관계가 있는지, 그리고 양자 역학에서 가장 유명한
원리 중 하나인 불확정성
원리에 대해 알아볼 거예요. Qiskit 교실에 오신 걸 환영해요. 여기서는 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 강좌에서
접할 수 있는 핵심 개념을 쉽게 풀어드리는 동영상 시리즈예요. 각 영상에는 설명란에
링크된 인터랙티브 모듈이 함께 제공되니 꼭 확인해 보세요. 오늘은 하이젠베르크 불확정성 원리에 대해 얘기할 거예요. 혹시
들어보셨다면 하이젠베르크에 관한 오래된 농담도 들어봤을 수 있어요. 어느 날 그가 운전 중에 경찰에게 단속됐는데, 경찰이 물었어요. 지금
얼마나 빨리 달렸는지 아세요? 하이젠베르크가 답했어요. 모르지만 제가 어디 있는지는 정확히 알아요. 이게 바로
하이젠베르크 불확정성 원리를 한마디로 요약한 거예요. 입자의 위치와 운동량을 동시에
완벽하게 알 수는 없어요. 보통 이렇게 표현하죠. 델타 x 곱하기 델타 p는
h/2 이상이에요. 여기서 델타 X와 델타 P는
위치와 운동량의 불확정도이고, H는 양자 역학에서 아주 작은 기본 상수예요.
하이젠베르크는 1927년에 전자의 위치를 어떻게 측정할지 생각하다가 이 부등식을 만들었어요.
전자의 위치를 보려고 광자를 쏴서 반사시키면, 그 광자가 어쩔 수 없이 전자를 건드려서 운동량을 흐트러뜨리게 되죠.
이건 단순히 측정이 시스템을 교란한다는 얘기가 아니에요. 우리가 자연에 대해 알 수 있는 것에는 근본적인
한계가 있다는 거예요. 이건 상보성이라는 더 넓은 원리의 한 예인데요, 자연의 어떤 측면들은
서로 양립할 수 없어서 동시에 관찰할 수 없다는
얘기예요. 예를 들어, 양자 객체는 때로는 입자처럼, 때로는 파동처럼 행동하는데
두 가지 행동을 동시에 관찰할 수는 없어요. 하이젠베르크의 위치-운동량 관계는 이런 상보적 특성 쌍 중
하나에 불과해요. 이 본질적인 불확정성은 양자 역학에서 위치나 운동량 같은 물리량을 어떻게 보는지와 관련이 있어요.
X와 P를 변수나 각 입자가 가진 본질적인 성질로 생각하는 대신, 양자 역학에서는 위치와 운동량이 연산자예요.
시스템의 성질이 아니라 시스템에 가할 수 있는 작업이에요. 지금 입자의 위치를 파악하려면
시스템에 연산을 적용해서 측정을 해야 해요. 이 연산이 이후의 다른
연산 결과에 영향을 줄 수 있어요. 비유를 들어볼게요. 마른 나무 한 조각을 생각해 보세요. 이 나무에는 여러 성질이 있어요.
위치, 크기, 모양 같은 것들이요. 또 불에 타는 성질과 물에 뜨는 성질도 있죠. 만약 이 나무가
양자 객체라면, 이런 것들은 그냥 미리 알 수 있는 성질이 아니에요. 대신 우리는 그것들을
관측 가능량이라고 해요. 시스템에 어떤 연산을 가해야만 알 수 있는 것들이죠. 그래서 가연성이나 부유성
연산자를 적용해야 하는데, 실제로 나무를 태우거나 물에 넣어
뜨는지 확인해야 해요. 이제 각 연산자의 결과는 적용하는 순서에 따라 달라져요.
가연성을 먼저 테스트하면 나무가 재가 되어버려서 뜨는지 테스트할 수 없어요. 반대로 부유성을
먼저 테스트하면 너무 젖어서 타지 않겠죠. 가연성과
부유성 연산자는 교환 법칙이 성립하지 않는다고 해요. 연산 순서가 중요한 거예요. 이로 인해
이 두 관측 가능량을 나무에 대해 얼마나 잘 알 수 있는지에 근본적인
한계가 생겨요. 측정의 맥락을 모르면 나무가 탈 수 있는지 뜰 수 있는지 확실히 알 수 없으니까요.
물론 실제 나무라면 반으로 잘라서 두 성질을 동시에 테스트할 수 있겠지만, 양자 입자에서는 그런 걸 할 수 없어요.
나무 비유는 어디까지나 비유일 뿐이에요. 불확정성은 순전히 양자적인 현상이에요. X와 P도 교환 법칙이 성립하지 않고,
이 비가환성이 바로 하이젠베르크 불확정성 원리로 이어져요. 일반적으로 교환 법칙이 성립하지 않는 두 연산자에는
각자의 불확정성 원리가 있어요. 불확정성 원리의 일반 형태는
이렇게 쓸 수 있어요. 델타 a 곱하기 델타
B는
12 곱하기 a와 b의
어떤 값 이상이에요. 여기서
이 괄호를
교환자라고 하는데, a를 먼저 적용한 후 b를 적용하는 것과
b를 먼저 적용한 후 a를 적용하는 것의 차이와 같아요. 여기 꺾쇠 괄호는
안에 있는 것의 기댓값을 구한다는 뜻이에요. 쉽게 말하면, 같은 측정을 아주 많이 반복했을 때
기댓값은 그 측정들의 평균값이에요. 오늘은 IBM 양자 컴퓨터에서 이 불확정성 원리를 실제로 테스트하고 검증해 볼 거예요.
qubit의 세 가지 관측 가능량을 살펴보고, 연산자들이 교환 법칙을 따르지 않는다는 걸 보인 다음,
이 qubit 관측 가능량에 대해 불확정성 원리가 성립한다는 걸 증명할 거예요. 먼저 qubit의
양자 상태를 시각화하는 유용한 방법을 잠깐 짚고 넘어갈게요. qubit은 블로흐 구면이라는 구 위의 어떤 점을 가리키는 벡터로 나타낼 수 있어요.
이전 영상에서 다뤘는데 설명란에 링크가 있어요. 여기서도 간단히 요약해 드릴게요. 이게
블로흐 구면이에요. 각 벡터는 두 각도 세타와 파이로
표현돼요. 0 상태는 북극에, 1 상태는 남극에 있고, 0과 1의 동등한 중첩 상태는
적도 어딘가에 있어요. 여기서 f는 중첩의 두 부분 사이의
상대적 위상과 같아요. 그래서 이 상태는
1/√2 |0⟩ + e^(iφ) |1⟩과 같아요. 여기서 i는 그
위상이에요. qubit의 관측 가능량을 측정하면, 결과는 항상 두 가지 옵션 중 하나예요. qubit의 두 가능한 상태에 해당하죠.
이제 할 실험에서는 세 가지 관측 가능량과
그에 대응하는 연산자 X, Y, Z를 살펴볼 거예요. 이 관측 가능량 중 하나를 측정하면 +1 또는
-1을 얻게 되는데, 각각의 확률은 블로흐 구면에서 qubit의 벡터와
측정 축 사이의 각도에 따라 달라져요. 예상하듯이 Z는 Z축을 따라, X는 X축을 따라
측정해요. Y는 Y축을 따라 측정하고요. 지금 관측 가능량 얘기를 하는 이유는, 양자
시스템에서는 측정 없이 시스템에 대한 것들을 그냥 알 수가 없거든요.
그리고 각 관측 가능량에는 대응하는 연산이 있어요. 측정에는 연산이 필요하니까요. 금방 와닿지 않을 수도 있는데,
x, y, z 각 관측 가능량에 대응하는 연산자는
각각의 축을 기준으로 파이만큼 회전하는 거예요. X는 X축 회전, Y는
Y축 회전, Z는 Z축 회전이에요. 그러니까 이 연산자들이 교환 법칙을 따르는지 확인하려면, 구면에서의 회전이
교환 가능한지 보면 돼요. 교환 가능하다면 불확정성 원리가 적용되지 않고, qubit의 X, Y, Z를 모두
완벽하게 알 수 있어요. 교환 불가능하다면 qubit에 대한 새로운 불확정성 관계를 찾을 수 있어요. 지금
공 위의 점을 잘 보세요. 먼저 X축으로 회전시킨 다음 Y축으로 회전시키면 여기에 오게 돼요.
이번엔 반대 순서로 해볼게요. 먼저 Y축으로 회전시킨 다음
X축으로 회전시키면 여기에 오네요. 확실히 교환 법칙이 안 되죠. 이게 의미하는 건
qubit의 정확한 X, Y, Z 값을 동시에 알 수 없다는 거예요. 불확정성
관계가 생기는 거죠. 세부 내용은 생략하겠지만, 결국 세 가지 불확정성
관계가 나와요. 델타 x 곱하기 델타 Y는
Z 이상, 델타 y 곱하기 델타 Z는
X 이상, 그리고 델타 Z 곱하기 델타 X는
Y 이상이에요. 즉, 어느 두 불확정도의 곱이든 항상
나머지 세 번째 관측 가능량의 기댓값 이상이에요. Qiskit을 사용해서
0 상태의 Z와 X를 동시에 측정하면 어떻게 되는지 살펴볼게요. Z 측정은 쉬워요. 이른바 표준 기저로,
양자 컴퓨터의 측정은 기본적으로 항상 Z축 기준이에요. 하지만 X를 측정하려면 기저 변환이라는 걸 해야 해요.
쉽게 말해 블로흐 구면을 회전시켜서 Z가 원래 가리키던 위치에 X가 오도록 하는 거예요. 이를 위해
Hadamard gate를 사용해요. 전체 quantum circuit은 이렇게 생겼어요. Z로 측정하고, Hadamard를 적용한 다음
X로 측정해요. Qiskit Primitive 샘플러를 사용해서 이 실험을 여러 번 실행하면
Z 측정 결과는 이런 히스토그램이 나오고,
X 측정 결과는 이렇게 나와요. 보시다시피
Z축으로는 qubit이 거의 100%에 가까운 확신으로 0 상태로 측정됐지만,
X축으로는 qubit 상태에 대해 거의 아무것도 알 수 없었어요. 0 또는 1이 동일한 확률로
측정됐는데, 이는 X에서의 불확정도가 가질 수 있는 최대치에 가깝다는 뜻이에요.
불확정도 간의 트레이드오프를 조금 느낄 수 있죠. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터에서 좀 더 잘 할 수 있어요.
Qiskit Primitive인 estimator를 사용해서 관측 가능량 X, Y, Z의 기댓값과
각각의 불확정도를 구할 수 있어요. 블로흐 구면에서 +X 방향을 가리키는 상태에 대해 해볼게요. estimator를
사용해서 이 상태의 x와 z에 대한 불확정도와 y의 기댓값을
계산해 볼게요. 이 상태로 Qiskit에서 이런 결과를 얻었어요. X와 Y의 두
불확정도의 곱을 구하면, 예상대로 y 기댓값의 절댓값보다
크다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 하지만 이건 특정 상태 하나에 대한 것일 뿐이에요. 이 부등식이
모든 qubit 상태에 대해 성립하는지 확인하고 싶어요. estimator를 다시 사용하되, 이번엔 파라미터 값을 쭉 스캔하면서
모든 파라미터 값에서의 기댓값을 구해볼게요. 여기서 스캔하려는 파라미터는
블로흐 구면의 각도 세타예요. 그래서 XZ 평면과 교차하는 호 위에 있는
모든 qubit 상태에 대해 부등식을 확인할 수 있어요. 이렇게 하면 각도 세타의 함수로 그래프를 얻게 돼요.
빨간 곡선은 두 불확정도의 곱이고, 주황색 곡선은 y의 기댓값이에요. 예상대로
x와 z의 불확정도의 곱은 y의 기댓값보다 훨씬 높아요. 하지만
y의 기댓값이 너무 낮아서 부등식을 만족하기가 그리 어렵지 않았어요. XZ 평면 위의 모든 상태에서 y 기댓값이 0이었으니까요.
비슷하게 세타 값을 스캔해 볼게요. 하지만 이번엔 XZ 평면이 아니라 φ를 π/
4로 설정해서 구 위의 다른 호에 있는 qubit 상태들을 살펴볼게요. 여기서는 부등식이
좀 더 엄격하게 테스트되는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 주황색 곡선과 빨간 곡선이 더 가까워졌지만, 빨간 곡선이 항상 주황색 위에 있어요.
불확정성 원리는 여전히 성립해요. 아직 모든 상태를 확인한 건 아니지만, 이제 감을 잡기 시작했을 거예요.
양자 시스템의 어떤 두 상보적인 측면에 대해서든 근본적인 인식 불가능성이 있어요.
이 qubit도 마찬가지예요. 불확정성 원리는 아무리 노력해도, 아무리 영리한 측정을 해도
모든 것을 완벽하게 알 수는 없다는 사실과 마주하게 해줘요.
정말 피할 수가 없어요. 믿지 못하겠다면, 아니면 믿더라도 설명란에
링크된 모듈을 확인하고 불확정성 원리를 이겨보려는 도전을 해보세요. 시청해 주셔서 감사하고, 다음에 또 만나요.